on this one little tangent
of um the future of psychedelics so
engineering new psychedelics
can you comment on maybe the the
chemistry and the biology of how
psychedelics work and where is the space
of possible
engineering of psychedelics and what
kind of things might they unlock
in terms of the possible places our mind
would be able to go and the
the effects of that of improving health
but maybe at the basic level of
chemistry
and the space of what could be
engineered
well you you reminded me it's not i'll
get to exactly what you said but you
reminded me of
a talk i heard by buck mr fuller
shortly before he died and what he
talked about
is how technology was making
things um ever smaller you know
that we are able to pack more and more
information into smaller and smaller
spaces
and that we're developing technologies
of communications with people you know
we now know the internet and things like
that but what he said is that he thought
the
eventual uh evolution of this sort of
research would move
from this miniaturization to telepathy
yeah and so it was like a shocking thing
for somebody like scientific like that
to say that yeah
so will we unlock those parts
where i talked about the collective
unconscious will we be
able to more consciously explore those
areas so i think that that's
a possibility there was um stan groff
who's you know the world's leading lsd
researcher
and has been my mentor his wife brigitta
they were talking about stories that
they had heard about um
mdma that um people take and then on top
of that they do 5-meo dmt
and so you get this ego dissolution but
underneath that you have this sense of
um ego sort of um sense of
self safety of self acceptance kind of
grounds it so
stan was like that's the future of
psychiatry that you can
watch without the terror of the ego
dissolution the sense that you're losing
your mind or you're going crazy or
you're dying or
you know that you have this grounded
sense of safety
while you're dissolving your normal
sense of how you see things
and being able to engineer in in a
fine-tuned way that
that exact experience may be fine-tuned
to the person yeah
as opposed to sort of this manual potion
that's uh through
through uh well i don't experiment
although i don't know about fine-tuning
things to the person in the sense that
um we believe there's this inner healer
this kind of you know inner healing
intelligence
we talked about it the body repairs
itself you know so
um i think we more need to
create safety for people and then then
what emerges will be customized to what
they need to be looking at from this
inner healing intelligence
at the same time we will move to
you know we we hear so much about um
the new approaches to oncology
where you know you you do um genetic
analysis of different kind of tumors and
then you have certain kind of
chemotherapy agents and you do like
personalized chemotherapy i think we
will have
more like personalized psychedelic
therapy but it'll be
more like a sequence of different drugs
that people go through over an extended
period of time and then you kind of
customize
what's next and sometimes you'll combine
different drugs together like this
5mu dmt and mdma or a lot of times
people do
lsd mdma combinations or psilocybin mdma
combinations
um chemistry and um
you know is not my strength uh i'm more
into
[Music]
clinical applications and policy but but
i can say that
from what i've learned from reading from
others and research done by others
that you know different psychedelics
have an
impact on different neurotransmitters
different other
parts of energies in the brain
the default mode network is
what's considered to be like our sense
of self
you know and it's this it's part of the
brain that's sort of is what i described
before scanning
the world and filtering information for
what's really
important to us and both
focusing us on things and also helping
us to ignore a lot of things
and the classic psychedelics all weaken
the energy in this default mode
system and therefore you get this flood
of information that you're not normally
paying attention to
and then you start seeing uh in more
creative ways or more
connected you actually move to uh beyond
the verbal kind of thinking into sort of
symbolic thinking a lot of times um
and that's where you sometimes get these
uh mystical sense of connection how it's
all one and
you get the sense also of
how big the universe is and how small
each one of us is
so there's a lot of work that sasha
shulkin and albert hoffman
who invented lsd and first synthesized
psilocybin on what they call structure
activity relationships
what is the structural of the molecule
and then how do you predict
what that new molecule that never
existed before is going to do
once you actually take it and
you can get close but you never really
know
until you actually take the drug and the
way that
sasha ran his experiments is that he
would take the drugs himself first
in low doses and he would sort of you
know step up the doses to have more
experiences if he thought it was
valuable he'd share it with his wife
anne
but then what they would do is if they
both thought it was valuable they had a
group of 12 people that they were with
for many many years
and they would distribute these new
drugs to these 12 people
and they would get the different
perspectives and he thought that 12 was
like a minimum number you know because
we're so unique how each of us see
things but then you kind of get a little
bit of a consensus on how a lot of
people are going to see it and then if
that
12 people were positive about it then
they would turn it over to leo zeff
we called the secret chief the leader of
the underground psychedelic therapy
movement and then he would start
exploring it in therapy
so there's um still a lot of mysteries
as far as structure activity
relationships and
it's not going to be the case that
people go into the lab and they tinker
with molecules and they know exactly
what they're going to get
and a lot of it has to do with the not
so much
chemistry as morphology you could say
the shape of the molecule and how does
that interact with receptor sites
and so we're getting better at modeling
all of that
um and how does that interaction relate
to the
the the morphing of the human experience
and deeply understanding that
perhaps there's no equations yet for
that kind of thing you really have to
build up intuition by experiencing it
and over time and
the sort of subjective self-report like
trying to build
an understanding of the effects of the
different chemistries yeah yeah you can
you can have approximate ideas but to
know exactly so
you know when i first tried mdma which
was 1982
and this was after i had done lots of
lsd and masculine
and mushrooms i was shocked at how
different it was than these other
substances
and yet how profound it was so are there
whole new kind of categories of classes
of drugs that we're not aware of that
would be
not so much this um like eco dissolution
or emotional well what mdma does
is uh reduces activity in the amygdala
the fear processing part of the brain
so it's not just chemistry but it it
routes energy throughout the brain in a
different way it increases activity in
the prefrontal cortex
so you think more logically though that
i think has an enormous
impact on the effect of mdma
the other thing it does is it increases
connectivity between the amygdala and
the hippocampus so it helps facilitate
um processing of things into long-term
memory
um and with ptsd trauma is like never in
the past it's always about to happen so
will we one time develop drugs that
would even be specific to
certain kind of memories we're working
with a woman rachel yehuda
who is um at the bronx va
and she's done some studies that are
with the epigenetics of trauma so she's
worked with holocaust survivors and
their children
and she has identified um
epigenetic mechanisms by which trauma is
passed from generation to the
generations
sort of like set points for anxiety fear
certain
things like that but the question is can
you actually transmit memories
from one generation to the next now
this is not um dna
changes which happen over a very long
period of time in the
evolutionary scale but within one
lifetime within
some experiences your epigenetics what
turns on the genes or turns off certain
genes that can
be impacted and that's what we know now
can be transmitted from generation to
generation
either by the father or the mother
through the sperm or the egg
so it's it's pretty remarkable so what
what
rachel's going to try to do is mdma
research for ptsd
and look at these epigenetic markers
before and after and see if they change
as a consequence of therapy so
will we develop one day certain kind of
chemicals that will be able to bring
certain kind of memories to the surface
that's not inconceivable
you